there are more than a thousand rivers
and canals in Bangladesh the sea level
in the Bay of Bengal is rising storms
and heavy rains are becoming more
frequent land is being eaten away this
family expects to lose its home soon
they don't know where they should go
when the time comes I'm I've done work
honey how do you wanna be their gloves
born here I've lived here all my life
I've seen two thousand on two and a half
thousand families lose their homes
because of natural disasters that come
from the sea communities around here
have left their schools their mosques
temples everything behind villagers say
there were plans to reinforce the
shoreline here but nothing happened
ma fazool haqq often hear such stories
he works for the global anti-corruption
organisation transparency international
he's a specialist in climate change
mitigation and adaptation measures and
their financing much of the land in
Bangladesh is just a few metres above
sea level climate finance is coming to
Valadez but it's not what we expect
right now it need to
increased we have received so far 700
for about 700 million dollar all
together but in between in among these
700 million dollar pallidus government
has the highest contribution
particularly the government has spent
more than four hundred million dollars
so far projects include the construction
of facilities such as schools that can
also serve as sturdy refuges where
people can shelter during storms and
floods but buildings like these are
expensive and they don't always go up
where they are most needed transparency
international monitors how and where
funds are spent a school that also
houses an emergency shelter has been
built here in Barre goona district near
the coast the problem is it's a long way
from most of the villages in the area
and not as single pupil or teacher is in
sight the question is whether millions
have been wasted here and if so why it's
from the climate fund program one of the
Climate Fund programs sometimes it's
difficult to judge that they're used
properly in all cases but this is a very
exceptional case that you find that this
school is not used properly actually why
this particular spot was chosen to build
the school is anybody's guess HACC
doesn't know or at least he won't say
voicing criticism can be very dangerous
in Bangladesh
as human rights organizations point out
critics of the government in dhaka have
a way of disappearing the German
ambassador Thomas Prince is not afraid
to speak his mind
many Bangladeshis would probably agree
with him even though they might not dare
to say so chug the co-op's Union I
consider corruption to be the greatest
barrier to development in this country
what this country needs is clean
government and clean public institutions
and above all it needs the political
will to make it happen but I see no sign
of that finish this market hall which
can serve as a cyclone shelter has been
built at another spot in Barr goona
district transparency international is
hosting a meeting for the villagers here
the NGO is keen to see local communities
get involved the meeting begins with a
call for everybody to join forces to
combat corruption then local people
voice their concerns why are the public
toilets always locked why don't the
drains work what about the road to the
market
yes for those of the Admiral I'm
grateful that we have a road to the
bazaar but it's in terrible repair and
there have been accidents some of our
suppliers were injured
this is bad for business mahadji Hassan
Khan represents the local government he
was at the meeting and says he will
follow up on the matters raised very
many markets in Bangladesh are close to
water the buildings that house them are
rarely able to withstand floods or
cyclones a shelter also has to be tall
enough or built on high enough ground
that people can shelter above flood
waters this shelter is still under
construction but quality issues are
already in evidence foreign donors are
threatening to pull out of climate
change related projects in Bangladesh
unless the authorities clamp down on
corruption the international community
and transparency international are also
calling for better financial oversight
and project monitoring government is
actually also eager to learn from these
sorts of things and they are actually
gradually taking these things in their
planning in their policy level policy
issues in their in their documents so
it's actually helping Bangladesh to get
more money from climate funds Bangladesh
is among the countries at most immediate
risk from climate change and is in
desperate need of all the help it can
get to adapt
you